[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen installiert
und familie
wir finden hier gerade in köln auf der
internationalen süßwarenmesse das ist
die weltweit grösste süßwarenmesse wir
sind wirklich hersteller aus der ganzen
welt produzenten händler und hier gibt
es nicht nur süße snacks herzhaftes
süßes gesundes ungesundes und wird
findet sie auf der suche nach den
neuesten trends die größten innovationen
wir werden uns an ihrer tasche hier
füllen für den kindergarten gestern
ihrer und für ihre freundin suchen wir
noch was glutenfrei ist und diabetiker
geeignet ist das heißt für jeden ist das
belegen jetzt los und nehme ich mit und
die letzten freitag trainiert dass sie
aber später losgeht
mein handy
[Musik]
hier
weiter gehts können wir fragen ob die
was uns haben
ob ich jetzt mal hallo wir sind mit
samira auf der suche nach dem coolsten
neuheiten
ab jetzt kann man drüber befragen
erinnern
gewiss der sonderreihe wir suchen die
coolsten neuheiten informieren
dann fange ich euch doch mal was wir
dieses jahr anfallen
ganz sauber stehen und fallen auch was
probieren
dieses jahr und tag sind produkte
gefüllt mit hochdruck und die sind
tatsächlich wird von händen da dürft ihr
gerne mal reingreifen probieren
wir können auch
tommy will auf danke schön wenn er dann
gedacht
lecker
das ganze nicht nur in bruchstücken die
haben ihr letztes jahr schon gehabt aber
wir haben dieses jahr schon
halloween edition von superhirn so
gehirn das kann man ja auch ganz schön
so viele sachen gemacht bin ist abgeebbt
genau diese bereit für das sauber weiss
man die hälfte ab und ich nehme die
andere hälfte geht
dankeschön und
sauer macht lustig gern
dem gewöhnlichen stand und war knapp
sieben prozent haben wir jetzt auch in
mini version in der st
wiederverschließbare auto stellen
ganz so einfach
immer noch sauer
die bedienung wenn wir die nächste wahl
findet dann weiß ich auch nicht mehr was
ich noch machen
vielleicht müsste man bald ins labor
stellen du hast noch wird
danke danke
wir gehen weiter auf die suche
[Musik]
also ich sehe schon der trend auf der
messe schlechthin einhorn aber auch vor
kurzem die eine und bizkit rolle gemacht
und hier sehen wir auch alles voll mit
einhörnern ein leben das eine
untersetzte wahrscheinlich dass selbst
ein haben schön bunt und jetzt schauen
wir mal was es hier alles gibt
[Musik]
mal bittet er
bis 10
petersdorf
wo ein wachsendes und ländern
dann soll man abreißen
lecker
yahoo
da kommen wir melden die jetzt
humorvoll die kenne ich aus meinen
videos die habe ich schon öfter benutzt
und natürlich so zum essen richtig
lecker die morgens die kann man auch
sehr gut einschmelzen auch damit backen
richtig genial und diesen offenen
stuttgarter raum sehr schönes fahrrad
steht ja von selbst
aber das ist ja das gibt es
deine freunde helfen
[Musik]
das sei der mieter hier haben wir mit
familie zusammen die letzten zwei tage
dekoriert also ganz viele tolle torten
wobei ich sagen muss der meere hat du
hast ja ein bisschen schneller dekoriert
also ich glaube hat jetzt nämlich eins
zwei drei vier fünf tore gemacht und ich
habe nur 124 34 hingekriegt kann mir
dekorieren bisschen weiter
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich hier gerade die torte
fertigt die hertie matrose seemann torte
mit den zucker schriften die sind echt
gut
[Musik]
beim aktuell weiter und ich zeig euch
jetzt mal den neuheiten kommen
[Musik]
als ich hier den finger in den
verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen kennt
er schon
ich habe ich schon öfter benutzt auch
letztes jahr will beim gold hab ich ja
auch schon benutzt kennt ihr auch aber
was richtig neu ist einfach hier die
bäcker stärke in kleinen päckchen
richtig cool zum ausrollen
denn wenn man von den ausdrücklich immer
am besten immer becker strecke nimmt
viele nehmen ja cool dass zucker aber
puderzucker klebt dann eben an den
händen an der arbeitsfläche und becker
stärkte ihm den kleinen portion ist echt
perfekt und was ich ganz toll finde ich
habe jetzt mit deko china zusammen auch
gemeinsam produkte wie zum beispiel hier
unsere gemeinsame blüten passte buyten
passte vista verwendet man für blüten
und damit kann man wirklich sehr
filigrane dicke teile modellieren und
wenn man zum beispiel führten passende
mit fordern vermischt hat man
modelliermasse um zum beispiel den teddy
sowie hier drauf zu modellieren richtig
genial
und ja das sind gemeinsame produkte und
ihr wisst ich arbeite ja auch schon seit
über vier jahren mit dem kopfkino
zusammen
das ist bei uns ein hersteller aus der
region auf dem fall also etwa 20-30
minuten von mir entfernt und werden
schon ganz früh zusammengefunden und
entwickeln hat auch zusammen produkte
also da kommt die kadenz eigentlich
gleich noch da kommt dann zu mittag isst
aber neue idee sondern wir das und das
machen und dann schauen wir einfach die
qualität an wir schauen an
das produkt und damit es eben gemeinsam
gemacht mir gehen würde darüber würde
das immer wieder
immer wieder erzählt was gibt's neues
als ich habe schon becker stecke und
blüten pasta gezeigt dass wir das auch
für meinen raumwirkung dritten klassen
mussten spricht nein
unser back transfers und tritt ja
richtig genial komplett gold holen ja
ich habe auch selber schwul ist
ich hab das schon länger halten als
muster und viele viele habe ich danach
gefragt wo gibt es also eigentlich jedem
supermarkt oder wenn sie schlau ist
indess listen wir sagen einfach in jedem
gut sortierten supermarkt bauen wir
druck auch ja das ist echt genial
vermutlich ja ganz gerne nicht nur für
backformen man kann es ja in der pfanne
benutzen wenn man zum beispiel ein
spiegelei mal ganz wenig fett
waffeleisen auf dem grill und ich gegen
offenes feuer sprühen und verbindet sich
noch für fondant orten milch die torte
so ein bisschen einsprühen um von dort
rüber zu legen also wirklich sehr sehr
viel zeit ist und sehr ergiebig
roger nießen viel reden oder redet zu
viel wird von der freund fragt ob er
hochdeutsch sprechen muss aber ich hab's
einfach untertitel was nochmal noch neu
ist ganz ganz tolle rosen ja eigentlich
acht stück
der familie auf ihre tolle hier sortiert
vier pink und lila
wir sind ganz toll
und was ist schön schon groß
und im gleichen stil auf und wenn man
den stehen nicht braucht kann einfach
wegschneiden für sonst echt super
auch schön kühn hochzeitstorte recht
cool was aber noch als option ganz
genial die zucker schrift und zwar kennt
ihr ja alle zucker schrift auf dem
zuckermarkt das ist aber meist ganz
lustig und hält zum beispiel nicht auch
von antworten dass ich auch nicht decken
und die zucker schriftlich echt super
also wirklich ich habe gestern schon
damit gearbeitet und vorgestern und für
samira auch super einfach zu dass er die
truppe einfach topform eröffnet einfach
nur schön
und die sind deckungs haben wir ganz
tolle farben also gelb schwarz rosa
silber gold grün weiß rot und blau und
bei den farben ersetzt praktisch den
sprit freutel außerdem ist kein
realizing wir machen keine eiweiß
spritztour und in den schritt freutel
ein film sondern einfach aus der tube
umfeld und auch ich hier geht der trend
natürlich wieder zum einhorn also dies
tatsächlich ein jahr
und hier hat man dann auf pflege
reporter das heißt wenn manchmal wirkt
es gar keine zeit hat murats geburtstag
steht vor der tür dann wackelt eben
schnell marmorkuchen oder eine
springende spielformen kuchen und legt
einfach den einhorn aufleger drauf
[Musik]
dass wir mit und hat die beiden einzigen
youtuber hier sind extra software müssen
sind die geräte sind auch eingeladen
worden beziehungsweise sie arbeitet hier
ich bin eingeladen
ja und du gefällst du hier ich war die
letzten zwei tage beim e coaching
entstanden acht orten dekoriert und hat
eine tochter gewöhnen
ich hab leider gerade mal sechs leute
die zukunft das macht sechs leute
immerhin mehr als sonst
hallo danke schön danke der bauern herz
von st der fall ist müssen noch mal kurz
hinlegen ich hab die minions entdeckt
kommen
[Musik]
berlin
ja komm mit mir wenn ich endlich auch
die putts geschmack
[Musik]
okay sind wie wild cherry berlin von
ihren fans eine challenge machen
wettbewerbs familia und zwar drehen wir
jetzt rasch und dann kommt da eine farbe
und müssen probieren und entweder
schmeckt gut oder das schmeckt furchtbar
furchtbar
da komme ich probier mal andrea okay
oder verschimmelte eier ab
11 redet man hoffe ich habe ich programm
nicht faul ist
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich dran aber lecker verfahren
betfair spur
ok entweder ist das erdbeer banane oder
verstimmung oder fisch
und 11
[Musik]
vor allem wenn man dann auch ein neues
gefallen wenn man dann weiß was ist
wahrlich verstümmelt oder verkörpert wie
schon beim und mainz noch tolle anderen
geschmack die wasserpumpen hatten wir
schon
antwort es war okay entweder 40 oder
erbrochenes musste wieder licht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
fritz nachstehen
[Musik]
von dem hier gibt's auf was ohne gezeigt
wie verzweifelt muss man fallen in den
kindergarten und diabetes dann gucken
wir doch mal was
mit
[Musik]
von mira kommunisten wirtschaft für dich
denn da guck mal was ist da was gibt's
da lustig
[Musik]
probier mal hier gibt es sogar in die
halterung also es kommt keiner itk
frauen durch wie kann man die hände
halterung haben kann die dran machen uns
hinstellen
der wird cool aus und hier auch mit
enten poco
[Musik]
die handy haltung mit der copaco war ich
sehr lustig deshalb jedoch ziemlich
lustig also den lutscher mit dem und
dran aber macht dann natürlich ständig
mit zucker direkt an den zähnen zumal
ich auch luther allgemein gar nicht mag
ich bin das ist das schlimmste tausenden
kindern geben kann nikolaus aber ist für
die szenen natürlich nicht mehr ganz
gesund
[Musik]
eckhof voll cool das kenne ich aus der
türkei und aus dem taxi und sogar eine
richtig coole süßigkeit
die tochter ist eine marshmallow masse
mit richtig leckeren streute und drauf
ohne richtig kunst für uns und ich so
liebt sie also wirklich genial bei jedem
türkischen laden besuchen muss man ja
auf jeden fall immer mitnehmen
und schwupps weg
hey ronaldo alltag komme ich mal ein
foto mit ihm machen foto da weiß noch
nicht dass sie auch fussball stehen
wahrscheinlich schon mehr tore
geschossen als duo aber was soll's zudem
geht weiter
[Musik]
sammler
es ist so kalt kommt irgendwie kommen
wir werden uns wieder auf
du kennst du das
hier sind sich ja
so kann es schon selber
[Musik]
red
da sein
[Musik]
weiter so
der schritt danke
ich probier mal
gott
das tier wahrscheinlich aus wie der papa
von battle aus die schöne und das biest
hat auch so eine coole bringen
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich aber im richtigen jahren
stand und zwar bei gnt die sind
spezialisiert auf natürliche farbstoffe
das heißt sie färben lebensmittel mit
lebensmitteln ihr seht ihr zudem gelb
ist ein konzentriertes gelb und streut
hier aus apfel aus mango für bis zu tron
und es steckt hier alles mit drin uns
damit werden eben auch zum beispiel
diese süßen gummibärchen eben gefragt
hast du dich
das schmeckt man jetzt natürlich den
apfel nichts heraus aber in der
lebensmittelfarbe doch schmeckt ganz gut
heraus kann das zum beispiel nehmen wir
von joghurt gießen oder auf dem feld und
hat dann für die kinder und so viel
leckeres eis gemacht
[Musik]
dann wäre auch nicht mehr mit unsere
große tor gemacht wege vielleicht nach
hause
ja das haben wir schon mal rüber zum
kabarett und jetzt noch kurz war es also
fazit von der messe ich habe natürlich
nicht alles gesehen aber die heimlich
gesehen habe waren ziemlich interessant
aber ich muss sagen wir haben die
innovationen gefehlt also was ich oft
gemerkt habe dass man einfach viel zeit
und jahr viel arbeit in die verpackungen
streckt das als das produkt ist
eigentlich immer das selbe haus wird neu
verpackt neue anlässe für halloween für
weihnachten um was zu verschenken
das finde ich schon ziemlich cool aber
natürlich auch nicht alles gesehen und
natürlich ein wenig gesundes tier auf
der messe gefunden außer ein paar
studenten fotos nec und wir packen das
jetzt alles ein bisschen was geht und
den kindergarten und den rest auf das
team mitnehmen also wird zunächst einmal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
mai
darf ich eine tüte haben was soll's
richten
[Musik]
daniel gar nicht
morath
komm du kannst es besser als ich komme
immer darauf wie bei dem bombardement
weiß auch
nein das ist mein papa machen samira
machtapparates code macht ja mehr als
sauerei
[Musik]
es ist
woga
[Musik]
sie schlug